who's the greatest comic of all time
well there I don't think there is a
greatest comic of all time
Norm Macdonald was one of the greats for
sure well by the way actually on that
topic what what do you think about is I
think as a person who is fascinated by
the fear of death and death I think it
was
a truly genius thing to release a
special after you're dead
I don't know how that worked I haven't
seen the special of you it's not yeah
it's it's um
it's called I think nothing special
which sounds like something normal to
say and it's basically him in front of I
mean I I imagine he wouldn't would have
wanted to edit it that way because it's
made to look nicer than I think he
probably would have preferred it uh but
it's him in front of the screen like on
a zoom call
doing jokes without lap cold really yeah
and somehow given his
like dry dark humor it works because
it's almost making fun of itself almost
making fun of that hole that we were
stuck stuck alone inside
and because he's still acting as if he's
in front of the audience and is almost
making fun of the fact that this is what
we're forced to do I mean it's quite
genius it's really well and the jokes
are really good but it also makes you
realize how important laughter is from
the audience the energy from the
audience because uh but there's also an
intimacy because it's just you and him
because you're listening to it you know
there's no audience yeah so that's I
don't know I think it's quite genius and
he is of course there's there's certain
Comics that are like
not only are they funny
but they're truly unique
and like they're they're they're not in
terms of
um friendship and all that kind of stuff
but in terms of Comedy they're an island
yeah it's like they you know Mitch
Hedberg probably is that of course a lot
of people that start to imitate them and
so on but it's even right Steven Wright
yeah I mean there's like people who are
like you know Dave Chappelle who's like
probably one of the greats but he's just
like raw funny yeah I don't know if he's
an island he's just raw oh yeah I know
what you're saying an outlier a unique
individual yeah he's just great
um Norm was definitely unique in his
greatness like like there's only one
Norm you know he's got a very specific
style is there a reason you guys weren't
it doesn't seem like he was you guys
were close I mean I loved him it was
great I always enjoyed talking to him
um we just didn't work together that
often we weren't around each other that
often that's all it was but it wasn't
like uh it was I loved him though he was
a great guy I had a funny story about it
Norm uh twice just randomly I was on
airplanes next to him yeah seated right
next to him just totally random yeah and
uh one time
we're on this airplane and we're having
this talk and I was like yeah quit
smoking uh I was uh smoking a lot and I
just yeah it's terrible terrible smoke
it's terrible for you and we have this
great conversation we get off the plane
and he Sprints towards a store and buys
cigarettes like in the airport and is
lighting it on the way out the door and
I go I thought you quit smoking I was
yeah I did but all that talking about
smoking made me wanted to smoke again
before he's getting through the door of
the airport he's lighting it up I can't
wait
he can't wait to get that cigarette in
him it was he was just so crazy and
impulsive and love to gamble love
gambling and in that way he embodied the
joke like you can't even tell that
certain people just like live
in a non-secular
ridiculous absurd funny way yeah that
was him I mean non-stop just there was
nothing artificial about Norm you know
that that was who he was his Brilliance
was his Essence that was who he was